and clapsync
this is markiplier power wash podcast
power hour with pals
that sounds great went through four or
five different iterations of the title
oh it's still going it's still to this
day there was another name that should
have been named that i've forgotten now
it was so genius and now it's gone so
it's completely out of the
out of the realm of possibility
washed away washed away
welcome to the power wash pals power
hour
there was another name and i've
forgotten him now and i can't remember
what it should be but there was an even
better name
[Music]
it fits with the game actually because
it's the first couple levels it's all
the repeating joke of they can't decide
what to name their company is that what
it is
yeah so you're actually on
any of this how do you ever know this
it's my job it's my job to pay too much
attention to this stuff yeah did you did
you do a video on this game because i
was always talking like this
not only did i do a video about this
game i dedicated it to you
so i'm glad that uh i'm glad that my
content fell on deaf ears
i've been watching your food theory
stuff i i haven't actually been watching
too much game theory it's all right
don't worry but you've been you've been
watching enough to dunk on my sexualized
pokemon i know right yeah yeah uh we can
get into that but uh
i wanted to start this off before we
even get going um are you a good power
washer i see your snubby little tiny
baby washer there
i you know i i haven't upgraded my
devices all that much but i'm a diligent
power washer it's not it's it's not the
tools i don't have many tools but i use
them well let's say that i will tell you
it is actually 100 the tools in this
game oh no really especially on this
level um if you don't have a range
extender you're going to have a real bet
[Music]
oh man well you know what it'll be a
good time because i'm spending it with
you all right okay i'm just going to
count on me having to do anything if you
if you open your tablet how much money
you got
uh okay
let's see we've got how do i open the
tablet again it's been a while i think
escape oh yeah there it is yeah i've got
437 dollars i've been saving i've been
i've been saving that to invest in like
uh an ira or something yeah no you
shouldn't do that yeah you're never
gonna make any money with that but it's
okay you got that i've got mine i
haven't even upgraded to the best one
because i think the one i have is is
okay so what we'll we'll divide this you
go up the stairs and take like the close
short range stuff and i'll work on like
the things that need like long range in
that way okay i am a very diligent
jumper i am i'm i did not skip leg day
you said that yeah but the diligence you
know it's it's good uh just use the
ladders and whatnot there's many
scaffolds here of varying size you can
use any okay great sounds like a plan so
uh usually i have i have not done this
in the past um and i should do this as i
should introduce
my guests as who they are this is
matthew patrick one of the most prolific
and uh i i say this with all the love in
the world because i am i am the same way
love uh uh meme
internet personalities in the world
i am i'm a walking meme without even
before memes were like relevant online
yeah i know and i say that because i am
also a uniquely memeable uh youtuber
apparently um but i see just as many
madpad memes game theorist memes uh i
forget who did it but there was someone
that was doing videos that was like they
stole your voice and like put it into an
ai generator i was talking about how
people get no [ __ ] and just like
stuff
it's it's great man i almost hired that
guy i'm like hey do you want to just do
the videos for me at this point please
just go for it they were so watchable it
was really yeah i feel like this is
better than the stuff i produce go for
it man there's also uh there's also a
creator on tick tock who does matpat
impressions um
you know talking about who the purple
guy is and this and that and i'm like
hey you got the voice down man just just
sit in the booth read the script and
you're golden yeah you got life to live
you gotta go on with that um
but i will say you have been on youtube
for quite a while and you have uh in and
this is kind of an oddity for people
that have been doing it as long as you
or i have is that you have kind of
stayed in
the public eye for a very long time i
don't really care about the how and why
and the like oh what's your strategy i'm
just like have you stayed sane this
whole time
to be able to make content and like deal
with drama and whatever and [ __ ]
happening i don't even know what
happened with the most recent thing in
five nights at freddy's um it went over
my head and but i i saw you made an
apology video i didn't watch it
unfortunately again only food theory i
was gonna say hey hey i appreciate you
watching food theory that uh that
channel monetizes well so thank you for
the higher cpms over there
that's what it's all about
about
baby
no yeah i mean but you bring up food
theory for and i think that really
answers your question in a lot of ways
where
for me
you know the content is always evolving
the the landscape is always shifting and
and the great thing about having food
theory now is is it's a completely new
category of topics to talk about it's a
completely different style of video and
so
part of my life is now that i have three
different channels that cover completely
different topics
i'm able to you know if something isn't
really particularly exciting or
interesting over in the gaming space you
have the film space hopefully
something's interesting happening there
there's like a cool small youtube series
or something like that or if that starts
to get boring you know food theory opens
up a whole new wealth of of
possibilities to to talk and theorize
about and and you know new videos to do
so really the
the shucking and jiving with kind of the
the content trends and things like that
like that's a whole other story in
surviving controversies and whatever
like that's that's a whole separate
thing but when it comes to just purely
like staying sane
on the platform while doing you know 10
years 11 years worth of content now it's
like
that's the way to stay sane is just and
i think you would largely attest to that
too right with you know your your arg
projects your uh you know in space with
markiplier the youtube originals things
like that like
it allows you to kind of express
different parts of your creative
personality and and continue to learn
even though you've been doing it for as
long as you have yeah i i would
completely agree with that and i think
people that have seen my content evolve
over time would agree as well um but
maybe in a slightly different way
because for me it's less about staying
sane and worrying about like things to
talk about because me and ethan we joked
about this with unisonness like you
could put a banana on the table and we
would make a 10 minute video out of it
right with no prompt at all it's like so
the the fun of creation i i always go
back to that that old fnaf adage the joy
of creation you know i
i really do truly thrive on the making
of things and and
like the the the bouncing of ideas back
and forth of people which is why i
always loved what you did with um some
of those videos talking about it i will
i remember this very distinctly um it
was one of the first times you made a
video i think about darkiplier i don't
really remember what the video was i
just remember that it happened because i
was i was up in seattle
and i remember i saw on my phone we me
and amy we were walking down um by the
the the shore front store place down
there
and yeah my favorite
favorite seattle storefront short place
yeah it's great and i saw on my phone
that you would post a video that was
like completely dedicated to something i
made and it was an incredibly
heartwarming thing i i stopped and i i
literally had to sit down and watch the
video right away um
mostly because i was like what what
horrible things is he saying about me
because that was usually the adage of
when someone makes a video about you on
the internet it's not a good thing
that's usually very bad
right when you're trending you're like
oh no my my stomach sinks down into my
chest yeah everyone is like every time
i'm trending on twitter everyone's like
what did he do and it's like oh okay he
just he pooped yeah i was gonna say
usually it's you your bowels have moved
in some way yeah exactly uh but i
remember i sat down and i watched and i
looked at him and i was like this is one
of the coolest things anyone's ever done
for me
and i know that like it probably wasn't
entirely motivated to be sweet uh but i
i do think a lot of it was just like an
appreciation for uh someone else's
creation on the platform and a
recognition of that and being able to
turn it into content is an even bigger
bonus and i think that like that was a
really nice thing and i just got to
thank you for that oh of course i mean i
thank you for
you know not
not to get too like self-congratulatory
around this stuff but like no thank you
for you know
creating stuff that is fun and
interesting and exciting and i and i
think
you know again to the question of
staying sane so many years into this
it's it's awesome to see
that the the most viewed videos on film
theory at this point are me covering
youtube first series by small creator
channels you know we're covering the
back rooms a lot these days we're
covering the mandela catalog these
digital first productions that are being
produced by independent youtubers doing
in you know on their own with small
teams and and like that is so exciting
to me and i think that's been
one of the coolest parts of of my
evolution as a creator
is you know being able to have a
platform now and and being able to in
some way pay it forward and put a
spotlight on to people who are doing
awesome cool stuff and who deserve
credit and who are pushing the the
limits of what it takes to
you know tell a story in 2022. that's
that's a really good way of putting it
because it is kind of paying it forward
right we as creators you know we're old
men by now you and i yes how old are you
i i'm sorry i know we're close in age
but just like uh remind me oh my gosh i
i i can't say it on on camera tonight
no no what am i i'm 30 30 35 ish
yeah yeah i'm up there i'm up there mark
i just turned into the grand pro of
youtube
in the terms of youtube we're we're
ancient dust we're practically falling
apart i mean i mean we're no rhett and
link but we're getting close
how old are they i know they're older i
always forget uh there what are they at
this i mean they're over 40. i think
they're 40
early 40s i think at this point yeah
early 40s okay that's not too they're
not dust in the wind yet but you know no
certainly rumble yeah
sure but no i think about that a lot in
terms of like content creation i i have
come very far in terms of my ability to
make content and i i i'm still to this
day trying to push my myself and my
ability and my knowledge and of course i
have all these projects that i'm
currently working on now just last week
i wrote like a hundred pages of script
um on two separate projects that like i
can't wait to get on because i love it
that's amazing yeah but at the same time
i'm trying to remember that the reason
that i make things is not just for
myself it is a lot for myself and it's
selfish but the other part of it is
to hopefully inspire someone else to
make something and that you know they
can see in themselves that they have the
ability to create and this
individualized like
people going out and making the back
rooms that guy who makes those videos
the ones that are the most popular i
think is like yeah kane he's 17 or
something right yeah he's super young
he's just a kid by all measures he's a
kid yep he is a via vfx artist who is
just really good you know as far as i
can tell he enjoyed the scp back when
back rooms was a thing and he's like hey
i'm gonna i'm gonna make my version of
the story and i'm gonna show the world
what i can do and lo and behold now he's
one of the biggest trends in horror
on on youtube and one of the biggest
trends in general on the platform it's
it's awesome it's so exciting and i
when when i get a notification of him
uploading i cannot wait to watch that
video yeah that's so cool i still have
yet to see any of them i i plan on doing
a backrooms uh style video uh in the
very near future um just having that
time because i'm gonna be going i'm
going to korea to film a documentary
next week oh really oh that's awesome
yeah about my mom so it's uh it's going
to be a nice personal story um and i
just get so behind on things but i do
remember like all this is for the next
generation like at some point my channel
will fall i've practically been trying
to get it taken down
um but you know i'll but i'll move on to
something else and i'll make things like
i have plans to make movies and you know
tv shows and whatnot but i don't think
like that i'm not doing that because i
want to like break into
the traditional media sphere it's just
like i want to try something new and
like i want to see if i can make it in a
movie um and all this selfish like talk
besides i know you got plans and i will
i'll ask about your plans but just on
the same topic um
do you worry
about new creators these days and the
speed at which trends can rise and fall
because that is the biggest drawback and
the biggest thing that i worry about for
people is that the the rises i talked
about this on several different um
topics and podcasts with other youtubers
but the rise with like new creators
these days is meteoric it goes higher
than ever before faster than ever before
but it also falls faster than ever
before and the cycle you could you've
seen i've seen the psychological
ramifications of that on creators over
our entire time period it's can be
devastating do you worry for creators
today uh hitting those peaks and valleys
uh i think it's one of those things
where
it honestly i think it's on a
case-by-case basis right i think it
depends on what the creator is
is popping into this world for you know
and what their expectations are i think
we're simultaneously dealing with
uh you know younger and and like you
said faster trends and younger creators
and things like that but also these are
people who
have grown up with these platforms and
have seen
trends rise and fall and you know
hopefully are familiar with it and so i
think
you know a lot of people and i would
hope that they're going in with a with a
healthy mentality of like hey it's
awesome that this took off and you know
this is this is my 15 minutes of fame
and and
let's see what i can do with it i think
i think more so what i worry about is
just the
the fact that it affects storytelling
you know the need to be
this need to constantly tell stories
faster and have more in it and super cut
things and this and that like you lose a
lot of
the ability to to tell slower paced
stories pensive stories um i think
that's to me the the more concerning
thing is we as as a viewership as an
audience as as people who watch online
videos things like that like the pace at
which stuff gets produced and has to be
kind of produced in order to like
maintain people's attention i think
that's what concerns me more mm-hmm
that's a really good point because a lot
of people that i talk to in traditional
media spheres you know my manager my
agency yada yada the people that do all
the caring about things that i don't
care about
they talk about this a lot with how
tick-tock is like shortening attention
spans but i don't think that's it i
don't think it's that attention spans
are getting uh shorter it's the demands
of the consumption that are driving
these shorter time frames tick-tock
works because you know vine worked and p
there is a demand in a market for short
content it's but it's not like youtube
is suffering the longer form videos on
youtube are getting longer um it's like
i i've sit around and watch three hour
videos about roller coasters from uh
what's the the channel um uh defunct
land you know i'll watch i love defunct
land love defund land
i'll browse through tick tocks and watch
like six second things but it's the
speed at which the internet is demanding
new content that is kind of affecting
the way stories are delivered and how
much can be physically put into
something by one person is starting to
really be stretched out even i as a
creator i am extremely good at what i do
i can make pretty much anything out of
anything i
i am blown away at which the speed of
some of these people are making things
i know what they're doing to get there
they're pulling all-nighters the demands
of it and this is why i'm like the worry
gets to me sometimes as much as the i
think the newer generations of creators
are more cognizant of mental health
deficiencies in terms of like burnout
and whatnot they're aware of it but
being aware of something is one thing
and experiencing like an ever increasing
demand is another it's it's like nothing
can prepare you for that so well and i
think that's that's that's definitely a
different concern right is is the like
you said the speed at which things have
to get produced and you know a channel
like game theory could never have
happened uh in 2022
youtube at this point you know the by
the nature of like we have a significant
team you know at this point i am
fortunate to be surrounded by so many
creative people who
you know trusted me to lead the ship but
you know who i am
just stunned by some of the work that
they're able to do to do in the
timelines that we're able to do it and
it's
you know and they always want to push
themselves further and they always want
to do better and and all of that but
you know to still get out uh a video a
week on game theory or three main
channel theory videos a week it's it is
such a difficult load to burden and we
wouldn't be able to do it without you
know this huge collaborative process
that that we have
back in the day i was able to get away
with you know matpat doing his one video
a month solo but now to stay relevant
and and
maintain what the platform needs and
demands you're just this constant churn
constant churn
yeah and then what you're trying to say
is like a new creator could not possibly
do that as it is right now because
starting it and getting to that level of
doing regular videos is it costs too
much money and it costs too much time in
terms of man hours or woman hours or
however many hours you want to talk
about it's too much
yeah it's it's even if you get that one
good video out you are then immediately
rolling into the next thing and by the
time you're doing it as a solo creator
unless you are you know killing yourself
or some sort of prodigy or whatever like
you are
you're already kind of
the algorithm has moved on past you
mm-hmm yeah you don't even get to track
your own growth because i i would love
to like have a conversation with people
that make like the back room stuff and
all these new and creators because i
would love to know what their process is
but given that eternal churn and like
the constantly increasing demands you
don't even get to step back and say oh
wow i've really progressed as a creator
of things my skills have built because
as soon as the numbers start going down
you're like i'm crap i'm [ __ ] i'm
terrible oh god it's over and all the
skills that i've built are worthless
because i can't even appreciate them i'm
not saying that's the right mindset and
it's not even the mindset i approach
things anymore anyway um but it's just
like one of those things where it's like
yeah i could totally see how people
could get wrapped up inward
sure well i want to go back to your love
of defunct land because because i don't
think i've ever heard you talk about
this but are you much of a roller
coaster enthusiast mark no no no no no i
mean yeah i love a good roller coaster
uh but i just like watching youtube
videos casually that's why that's my
go-to method of consumption i don't
really watch tv shows i don't have time
to sit down and get into a show um say
for maybe alone i've watched uh me and
amy we watch alone sometimes
but for the most part we're just popping
on youtube videos we're just watching
any random stuff that comes across the
recommendeds you know
and uh so when it comes down to like
watching things what little time i have
is just youtube videos or tic tocs
sometimes i've kind of like increased my
amount of tick tocks lately
oh man they're getting you to increase
the amount of tick tocks they know what
they're doing oh man oh that for you
page algorithm that thing is really it's
scary good i know they must be probing
into my personal information like i
think we all know that but god damn
those recommendeds really come up spicy
yeah no right it's it's it's really a
smart smart algorithm speaking of uh
have you ever taken like the
myers-briggs personality test or
anything like that that kind of like
quantifies what your personality is
because i know that these algorithms
really like you said they really
pinpoint who you are and what you like
to watch and so i'm curious have you
ever done something like that is that
the four letter uh yeah that's the four
letter one yeah well i'd have to alt tap
oh let me i've done a video on it i
don't remember what the answer was but i
can look it up and tell you
well how long was the video because i
know mine has changed with time right
like so it's one of those things that we
ask a lot of the people who come out to
team theaters to take just because
it tells us a lot about who they are how
they work and and how we can best work
with that person uh so so we can you
know really succeed together and and
i've i found it to be really helpful um
and so i was just curious because i'm
you know
i i'd be curious to see what your
results were according to this weird
internet site it says enfp but i don't
think that i'm that enough did i
is that what i took
i have no idea
there's an extrovert feeler that makes
sense uh ian you're an intuiter so that
means you're looking at data and
extrapolating to move forward uh i could
see that in your personality and then
and then p
ah i would be surprised on one hand i
could see you as a p but on the other
hand i'd be surprised if you were just
by the nature of how busy your schedule
is
e-n-t-p-a is what i got when i took the
test okay tpa which is debater i don't
know yep okay yeah i don't put any stock
into any of that [ __ ] but what are
you
uh i am an entj
uh and i actually split a couple uh
because i'm entj which is thinker
extrovert the n is the intuitor so
you're looking at data and kind of
extrapolating outward and then uh j is
you have to be a planner or you're kind
of ver you prefer things organized
rather than like let's just go by the
seat of our pants kind of thing
i love seating your pants man yeah i
love it
yeah you like the seat of my pants mark
oh i love the seat of your pants it's
just so incredible it's good right now
it's a little bit sweaty i'm on a
leather couch it's not great so i'd hate
to tell you about that one
um i've always enjoyed that just because
you know i'm i'm a psychology nerd i
studied psychology and neuroscience and
stuff so i i find it useful but at the
end of the day like
i see why people don't because it's like
oh you're just answering the questions
that the test gives you and you're
feeding it back what you want to hear
and it's true but like hearing it in a
different context or kind of rephrased
back at you sometimes gives you clarity
i think yeah self-understanding i'm big
about i'm i'm all about like trying to
be in tune with who you are and like get
a get a deeper understanding of the self
uh but at the same time i always i
always shy away from those things
because i do think it's easy answers
instead of like actually looking in and
discovering yourself it's just one of
those things where the only time you
really know yourself is in the the most
dire of situations when you're at the
extremes of your personality do you
really even understand who you are and
what you're willing to do and what
you're even capable of
as you're doing it and i think those uh
those moments can't be quantified in an
online quiz
but at the same time like if it helps
someone comes to understanding i got no
problem with it sure no of course
this is this was always one of my
getting to know you questions i've never
gotten a chance to to truly you know get
to know you outside of projects marks
i'm curious like if you were if you were
represented as a muffin flavor
so
if your personality were represented by
a muffin flavor not a muffin flavor that
you necessarily like to eat because
that's always like i like blueberry and
it's like no if your personality were
distilled into the essence of a muffin
flavor what muffin would you be mark
man
uh it does it have to be a muffin flavor
that exists
uh no you know it can be whatever
whatever muffin whatever combination of
flavors you think is is the essence of
mark right okay so
if it was gonna be me it's not gonna be
something that is always pleasant
uh so it's gotta be it's gotta have some
spice to it it's either like a spice or
way too much cinnamon or something like
that you know it's got some some spice
to it um
but you know there's got probably some
like a spicy chocolate muffin i would
probably put it like that you know
cinnamon chocolate yeah no not even
cinnamon
let's get the cinnamon out of there but
let's let's get some actual like there's
capsaicin in this muffin
it is actually spicy yeah like like like
a chili muffin like a hot a hot chili
muffin a hot chocolate muffin that's but
yeah not chocolate like hot chocolate
but like spicy chocolate muffin
cool
like a spicy mexican chocolate right
yeah yeah just like that nice and what
how does that reveal someone because
you're right we've never actually sat
down and talked as just two humans
talking it's almost always been about a
project or work
right it's either it's either a project
or it's on camera or it's you know i
think the closest we came was after
both heist and in space but that was
also surrounded by a bunch of people you
know and that's always a very different
context as well yeah it always is um
yeah so what type of muffin are you
uh actually it was funny when you
started to talk about cinnamon muffins
because for years i've always said i'm a
cinnamon muffin um yeah uh and
everyone's like that's that's not a
muffin i'm like yeah it is but uh you
know a little bit a little bit spicy a
little bit sweet
um you know a little bit intense uh you
know a lot of people
will like you but there are going to be
people who really don't like your flavor
so you know love it or leave it i guess
yeah it's it's kind of like a uh
polarizing muffin choice but people seem
to constantly go back to it for some
reason
yeah there it is i'm a muffin with a
fist in it and it reaches out and it
punches you in the teeth every time you
go to bite it but then somehow you just
keep going back
almost like i think actually i'll take
it back it's like cinnamon chocolate
spice a fist and uh
let's say uh cocaine
there's
something to get people addicted and
they come back for more
that's my muffin i'm the drunk spicy
chocolate drug muffin this is the
elusive cocaine muffin wow
oh man well you know if if you wanted to
get this this video demonetized it just
happened now so there it is one step
closer to getting kicked off the youtube
platform
demonetization is not getting kicked off
i so many of my videos are demonetized i
just the thing is like a lot of people
are like oh i know there's a whole thing
about like age restriction and stuff
like that and and yes i it's a it's
[ __ ] ethan just got uh his 10-year
anniversary video age restricted no clue
why the most absurd thing i've ever
heard it's just like baffling but at the
same time like usually when it comes
down to those things i just i've never
talked about it and i never even fight
it because i just don't really care um
like it's like one i'm in a fortunate
enough position and i know this is
fortunate for me to say just like if a
few videos get age restricted or even
half of mine i'm still gonna be fine
i'll i i'm still gonna make things and i
don't i try not to like change my
content for the sake of youtube's
guidance
um because being monetized is one thing
if my video gets removed that's a
problem uh but usually i'm just like
whatever it is what it is and i'll just
deal with it um but at the same time you
seem to be like very mindful of
food theories better monetize uh you
know like uh age restriction is
something to be aware of cursing is is
obviously something control um do you
think about that a lot like in terms of
the videos you make oh yeah i mean
my
i'm an uber nerd and i overthink
everything right like that is just who i
am but it really is born back to the
early stage of the channel right where
again going back to the idea of like how
could game theory exist in 2022 if i was
just starting off from scratch
it would be incredibly difficult because
it would take a hundred hours to produce
a single video um between all the
research that goes in all the scripting
you know all the the animation
whatever you wanted to call what i was
doing in the early days um but it took a
long time for me as someone who wasn't
skilled in a lot of that stuff and so
very early on in my career as a content
creator i guess you could say before i
even realized that that's what i was
going to be
it was how do i squeeze
every last view or every
you know how do i make this this video
work as successfully as possible
with the platforms that it's going on so
that way my effort wasn't wasted and the
next thing that i move on to it buys me
enough time for the next video honestly
um and so that's when i really got
involved in the analytics and my
background is with neuroscience and
theater and so really
those two specialties are a really nice
balance of the creative half of what the
platform is as well as the analytical
half you know it's it's a creative
platform that's built by engineers and
where content is is measured by
numbers and so for me i got really
invested in the early days about like
okay well what can i do to experiment
and find new things to
boost the retention time a little bit or
you know get people to engage a little
bit more and this and that it was it's
fun but and it empowered me and it
taught me a lot about how the platform
works and this and that and i try to
pass it on to other people at this point
but yeah from the early days when you're
only uploading a video a week and it's
taking a lot of time and manpower and
stuff that's that's kind of where i
found it man i don't spend any
brainpower thinking about stuff
i really don't sometimes i do but really
i i don't it always fascinates me um
because i think you are in an
interesting
uh crossroads not a crossroads that
sounds confrontational it's like an
intersection of specific talents because
it is that neuroscience and theater
background i've always said that you
have a great performative uh personality
you are good on camera you're good at
improvising and you're good at like the
the actual performative aspect there are
many youtubers and many other people
that are trying to make careers on on
the internet that are not i'm not
calling anybody else specifically about
this you all know who they are they
literally were not built for performance
and that's okay some people are not
but at the same time there are a lot of
people that try to brute force it with
just that technical aspect but i think
what makes your your content and your uh
longevity really stand out is that you
are able to do both and you really
really do think well in terms of both
what is entertaining and what is like at
the right
uh what's the big uh it's it's in uh you
know all the tech spheres that's the one
word the zeitgeist you know
i hate that word so much just like i
really hate the word it's like when
everyone someone calls like uh someone
else he's a savant oh he's just haunted
there's a genius i hate these terms but
really i do think that you you kind of
like always tune in to what is topical
and somehow make it entertaining which i
think is a unique set of talents well
chuck thank you i mean it's it's always
i i always think that it's
i want to learn right like the impetus
of the channels for me was an
opportunity for me to to teach myself
something new and to have an excuse in
while i was looking for jobs and no one
really wanted to hire me to
have an excuse to show them like hey i
can do things i can do smart things but
also just to keep my brain active and
the cool thing about youtube and the
frustrating thing about youtube is
that it's always changing and it the
content is always changing the audience
is always changing youtube themselves
and the policies that it adheres to and
what it's advertising and stuff like
it's always changing so
on one hand it would be one thing to say
like oh yeah i've been a youtuber for
for 10 11 years and i'm i'm getting
bored with it or whatever but on the
other hand it's like no it's it's
one of those jobs that is constantly
forcing me to find different ways to
evolve as a creator and different things
to expose myself to and how do i grow up
on this platform
as as a creator as as a viewer as
someone who's in this space
and that's what not a lot of people
realize is that you do need to grow up
with it i i talk about this a lot you
know in terms of drawing from this well
of inspiration that you hide that you
have inside of yourself um and
eventually you'll you'll run dry no
matter what you do you'll run dry
eventually and it's just a thing where
you got to go live more life and come
back to it uh and and learning and
growing up with your audience is part of
it my audience has grown up with with me
i've found more people on the way but i
think people who watch these uh creators
online for a long period of time if they
don't change if they do not evolve as a
person as much people are like you've
changed i'm this old mad pat you know
[ __ ] like that the if they don't see
change then it's weird it falls into
this uncanny valley where it's like
they're not human they've stayed the
same they've stagnated it's not what
real life is people change all the time
their taste change my videos have
drastically changed in terms of my
performative ability technical ability
but also just like because i've changed
i'm different um but at the same time
i have a question for you yeah okay yes
youtube dies tomorrow what do you do
oh youtube dies tomorrow what do i do um
you know what i would
i would
either
just retire you know i'm in a fortunate
enough position where i could retire and
it would be okay um
but i think more so and and i think what
i would do then is i would just pick up
projects to help
you know uh
i guess
my go-to answer is usually like oh i
would apply to youtube like if the
channel died i would apply to youtube
and try to kind of like serve as an
internal voice of someone who's been on
the platform for a long time who
represents creator interests and who can
like speak to a lot of different facets
of what it means to be a content creator
in the digital space but if youtube
itself died um
yeah i i mean like you said i've i've
changed and i've grown i have a family
now i have a kid and i'm so excited to
teach him
everything about the world and so
you know i've for the last 10 years been
teaching people
both useful things about physics as well
as not so useful things about haunted
animatronic pizzeria restaurants and
you know and so i i think after doing
that sort of education for people over
the years and and stuff i'd love to be
able to focus a little bit more on the
little guy that's that's in my life and
i can i can teach him all those things
you wouldn't cry
would i cry you wouldn't be sad just a
little bit
oh i mean absolutely i would be sad but
you know no wrong answer boo boo no
i mean
mark i i think i think you would be sad
too right like for as much as
as as much as this platform is is
frustrating and how much of it is as a
grind and and all of this stuff like it
is a a huge part of of a huge chunk of
my and your life and so
to say like you wouldn't at least be a
little sad to see a part of
of what has made you you disappear and
die and especially if youtube itself
disappeared and all the videos and all
the work from a decade of my life
suddenly goes away and and i can't
revisit
you know i i that's what you were saying
with unassanus right was that you
appreciate the things while they well
they're here but there is a sadness and
a little bit of uh you know regret to
see that sort of thing go away mm-hmm
um so yeah i would i would be sad but
you know then then you move on and you
you find the next thing in your life
yeah i can't deny that there wouldn't be
a hint of sadness i like to say that
would be like emotionally dead and
ignorant of my own feelings that would
be very sad to see and especially for
all the other people that would be out
there who lost that's things that you
were talking about my personal feelings
sort of my videos aside because i would
i would not really miss them um
but part of me would be
outside of the sadness and obvious like
melancholy behind it i would be
incredibly excited
and and let me tell you why let me tell
you why is is not because of
like ignoring the sadness that's there
it's suddenly this vacuum
i love change that's me a lot of people
really hate change i adore change i'm an
agent of change i love
doing anything that changes things up uh
even if some people could point to
specific examples where i hold on to
certain formats and whatever i love this
idea that the entire ecosystem of the
internet the pipeline of content that
that that is the pillar and lifeblood of
creativity and the livelihood of so many
people suddenly gets upended and the
reason that's exciting for me is because
that that that moment is the catalyst of
the greatest creativity that would come
out of the internet in like recent years
it would be suddenly a vacuum a demand
for content and creators that were just
like suddenly ousted where would they go
how would it evolve when people would be
forced to change oh man i would just i
would be so excited to see what would
come out of it because i feel like it
would just be like the most profoundly
interesting few years afterwards as like
things just rehash and re-stitch
together me personally among them i
would be like in the mosh pit throw in
elbows just like making it would be the
wild west of content and you don't think
that would be just a little bit of
exciting
i mean it would be cool
i mean it would be exciting but where
are you making that content like and i
think this is the thing like not not not
to overly challenge you or anything but
like you know people can be creative all
the time wherever
the and and that mosh pit is happening
right now as you speak mark the you know
the the question is where are those
people getting seen because creative
people since the beginning of time have
always wanted to to find a platform
for
their creativity to find a place where
their voice can be heard and one of the
things that i i love about youtube and i
love about this platform is
in a lot of ways it is a a meritocracy
you know where you learn the platform
and and yeah there's
it's it's become less so over the years
and that's like a fine nuanced point but
like more so than
you know
traditional media television movies
things like that where you had to be in
l.a and you had to know the right people
and you had to come from the right
family or know the right you know x y
and z like youtube democratized
entertainment in a lot of ways and so
hey if you are keen pixels and you have
the back rooms and you're just a
talented vfx artist awesome you know
someone on red is going to pick that up
it's it's going to get signal boosted
you're going to grow a little bit you
know a content creator is going to react
to it we're going to do a theory about
it whatever and bit by bit you're going
to grow that audience and suddenly
you've succeeded in the mosh bit you you
found your way and
you know i still think that youtube is
in a lot of ways a place where that that
mosh pit happens and it is a platform
that
formalizes it to some extent but still
incentivizes that creativity um whereas
i think if all of a sudden it goes away
you know now
what are you left with you know
sure go for go for it no this is this is
exactly my point because there is the
mosh pit right now with the tick tocks
and instagram there's so many different
ways that people monetize in that aspect
you're right it would create a big
vacuum of established things but how
many people like you and me who have
said to this question yeah i'd be fine i
could retire but how many people are
still like incredibly hungry for it the
thing the thing that these other
platforms don't realize that is that
youtube acts as a nice sponge for
creativity and that the competition that
exists on those platforms is dulled
because of how established some routes
are in youtube you don't just get new
people coming in you get old people that
suddenly have to be like oh god i have
to do something else but they have the
skills behind it to do it they're not
even going to just make content they're
going to make their own platforms with
which to do it because how many
youtubers have you talked to that's like
man if i made a new youtube i would make
it so much better and whether they're
right or wrong you know right sure for
all of youtube's flaws i do like the
platform i i still think it is like what
you said it is one of the the places the
few places on the internet that has
actively taken a role to try to
encourage people to express their
creativity and make a living out of it
that is rare and that is not a guarantee
in the world as many other platforms try
to be there there's still like many good
things about youtube policies aside it's
still a good place to make stuff but
imagine like the rush is not just it's
not even just a mosh pit anymore it's
it's like if uh when a business
collapses in the like a big huge
business collapses in the world or gets
absorbed like it's just a frenzy
entering into this fear it's like the
competition is what drives and that's
like what makes me excited it's just
like seeing what these people with all
of their skills suddenly you see a bunch
of youtubers have to like suddenly start
doing tick tocks i think that's so funny
because like so many of them are going
to fall in their face their skills don't
work but some of them are going to be so
unbelievably good other tick tock people
are just going to be like what the hell
is i have to do that now it's like it
holds people to a higher standard both
like in all aspects and that's what i
find exciting about it
i mean anytime like here's the thing
anytime there is an opportunity for
someone to to be creative like i love
creativity and like i said it's it's one
of those things that i love about
where i
exist at this point where i am
surrounded by people who are
also as passionate about the their
creative work and the stuff that they're
putting out into the world as i am and
it is so refreshing and so awesome and
you know being able to to watch these
creators uh you know have have a place
to to kind of express themselves it's so
it's so cool yeah it is it absolutely is
uh but that doomsday scenario won't
happen like youtube's going to be around
here for a while until it slow it'll be
a slow death not a quick death it's not
going to get pulled to plug anytime soon
what do you think comes next though like
what is what is the next iteration of
content mark next iteration of content
uh ai driven stuff sadly um
maybe this is still way down the road i
think that there's there's um still a
long ways to go before it encroaches
into the territory of like say making
its own videos and whatnot
but have you seen some of the recent
advances in terms of ai image generation
yes it's it's wild we've uh we've
actually wanted to do a a series of
videos across all the channels of ai
writes a game theory film theory food
theory
we
have
we've cycled it through the ai
how many times i we we ingested
most of the episodes for all the
different channels and we got some okay
results back we weren't fully satisfied
so i think we're gonna run it through a
couple more times it's been a process
that we've been doing for about the last
three months or so um
but yeah that's it's it's wild right
same thing with the the the dolly stuff
oh my god the image creation it's it's
scary it's it's so scary because it
if you haven't been paying super
attention to it to the people listening
out there like you may not realize just
how quickly this has started to evolve
mid journey is probably a popular one
that many people know dolly being the
most well-known version but mid-journey
has been working under the hood and
slowly making strides in just three
months it went through two version
updates um the third version was
released and it increased the fidelity
of their results tremendously like it
was stunning the jumping quality and
then they released version four with the
advent of i think it's called static
diffusion and like a different method of
image generation you'd have to look into
the papers to know the technical things
i do not um but the quality level is
it quickly became like oh that's fun it
makes kind of pretty pictures but
they're a little weird to
what the hell am i looking at this is
amazing and it terrifies you it really
does kind of scare you not me again i'm
like this is super cool i think it'll be
a tool for people to use um but it can
be just like wow there was a case on
reddit that some people might have seen
where someone entered their mid-journey
creations they they printed it out
upscaled it printed it on a big canvas
and entered it into an art competition
and they won first place
whoa i did not see that that's wild yeah
ai generated art won first place in a
real life art contest and rightfully
people were very pissed of course
and i think they have they they're like
that's rightfully so they should be
pissed about that there should be rules
about no ai generated or in those
competitions but it made a point it made
a point that this art was good enough
that other people objectively looked at
it and stacked it up to things that
humans made and said unanimously that it
was better
and that is an interesting crux in the
world of computer generated content
yeah very much yeah that's a wild story
what was that what was the image if you
don't mind me asking it was a space art
theory uh i could probably like like see
anything space there i'm so sorry no
when's when space you're gonna happen
i'm contractually obligated to say that
anytime someone mentions the word theory
so all right of course uh but uh they
can pull up the image but it is like
they had three different prints that
they made of various and admittedly
looking at them they are really really
incredible works of art but they were
not made by a human hand which does
impact the art it's no question that it
is art because it is like the meaning
behind it is there and the feelings that
it evokes even if it's outrage that's
art to me if it makes someone feel
something that's art but just the idea
that the computer generating could be
made from a prompt and
basically win out over pure human talent
and pure human hard work i don't know
what the other members of the contest
maybe they were crap maybe it was just a
bunch of other garbage attractions like
it was like it was a washout bar and
else was bad i'm not saying that it
could beat everybody but the fact that
it could beat anybody is
really really surprising what do you do
do you have do you have a favorite piece
of artwork
mark or do you have like a genre of art
that you respond to because uh this
summer i was fortunate enough to spend
uh in london so i spent two months there
went to all different
art museums saw a lot and uh you know
the tate modern in london is is so
incredible and it's full of so many it's
it it's full of all this unusual modern
artwork and you know some of it i like
some of it i'm like is that really art
but all of it makes me think and
question and i think that is what's so
exciting about a lot of that and so i'm
curious you know as someone who is
very well versed in in a lot of creative
pursuits and endeavors and is it's
constantly learning and and looking to
improve like what is there something
that inspires you or something you're
like i really respond to that
emotionally
here's the thing like i have an
appreciation for art but i don't pursue
it right okay so i'm not going out to
museums to look for inspiration or
anything i'll go to a museum and i'll be
like you with the modern art you'll be
like some of it'll be like incredibly
evocative and i'll be like i understand
this completely it really speaks to me
and i love the way it goes out there and
others i'm like this is a cup on a stand
and this is clearly stupid
and i'll say as much and i have no no
qualms with uh mincing words about it
but at the same time like i i never look
really to pursue inspiration from places
like that so i couldn't really tell you
like one thing of art that i that i
love and really respond to and go back
to but sure what it is is like i will
find something or like i'll come across
something and it'll speak volumes to me
and it'll be like this is wonderful this
is incredible i'm so glad this happened
upon my path and it now impacts me in
that way but i can't do it it's the same
with music like i'll appreciate music
when it comes by and i'll be like that
was incredible i'm so glad that i heard
this but i will never ever go out of my
way to find music actively and yeah it's
the same with art i'm i'm just so busy
in what i do um and with what i have
like it's it's the same with like having
inspirations for heroes i don't really
have any inspirations or heroes i'll
come across something and i'll be like
that guy did something real good or that
girl did something real good but that'll
be the end of the story i'll never
pursue it deeper and i don't look for
that kind of stuff um yeah not saying
it's better or worse it's just like that
is just what it is yeah that's just who
you are and how you operate absolutely
do you do you go to museums on occasion
i i do uh i
i think it's i don't know i i like
just
i i love learning right like my father
when i was growing up he
i mean he's been hugely influential to
me in a lot of ways both
you know with with the channel and with
kind of my mentality as a human being um
you know he
he loved reading conspiracy theories
books about conspiracy theories things
like that when i was growing up and he
didn't necessarily ascribe to them but
he was interested in them and he kept an
open mind to like
things that you know might be
not offensive but like other people
would just dismiss is kind of silly and
he just loved to learn
and
it's one of those things where he taught
me at an early age he's like the best
thing that you can be is a student of
life
and and never stop learning and and
again like that is how i've always
operated and so
you know if i have the chance to
go to an art museum and have an opinion
or figure out what my opinion is on
a certain artist or a certain work of
art or if there's an opportunity to
you know go to a concert that might be
outside of my wheelhouse and just try to
kind of expose myself to that's i love
that stuff um
because then i'm able to have an
informed opinion rather than
making a prejudgment off of it or or
whatever like if you can go to a party
and have an interesting conversation
about an experience that you've had a
concert you've been to a show that
you've seen whatever like life is all
about accumulating interesting stories
and opinions and and for me
that's that's kind of how i operate and
and going to museums gives me a lot of
that that education mm-hmm i i think i
identify with a lot of that and i'd say
that like relatively we're fairly
similar people but i think with one key
difference whereas you're like never
stop learning i'm never stop doing
uh interesting it's a similar it's a
similar philosophy and like the
difference could probably be lost to
most people but really like um not that
you don't do a whole hell of a lot
because you do don't get me wrong um but
for me it's like instead of like
learning about what my opinion about
something is or how i feel about
something i have to do it first
to know how i actually feel about it um
and i'm always
i've always have that mentalities like
i'd rather do something and then see how
i feel about it after i'm done with it
um because i did that with music and
like performing music i i for a very
long time there i pursued it extremely
hard and i practiced every day for about
a year and a half straight and i
performed it on stage and i did that and
then when i was done with it i said no i
don't like it and then i stopped doing
it but i had to know that before i could
say anything about like the the reality
of it and i'm not saying like my
mentality is more valid than yours
because obviously i can only do so much
so i can't really but i'm the same way
in terms of learning i always want to
learn more things because i do want to
be able to like back up my [ __ ] when
something however i'm ignorant to a lot
of things and usually i just go like i
don't know what i'm talking about so i'm
not going to say i don't have an opinion
and that infuriates people a lot of
times whenever someone asks me a
spinning or something i'm like i don't
have an opinion i don't know anything
about that i say that a lot and it's
just like that infuriates people people
are like how can you not have an opinion
on something i'm like i just don't care
about it i haven't done anything about
it
therefore it's nothing it's blank to me
uh
hey good good good on you to recognize
that i think you know that's that's one
of the tricks of of where we are in the
modern day right where people
don't
have that sort of knowledge or or that
experience but then they they're still
going to have an opinion about it
because
they just you know they think they know
or they're convinced that they know when
when in actuality they might not yeah my
my biggest fear is always standing on
the peak of mount stupid you know the
dunning-kruger effect
yeah absolutely
yeah yeah no i just i i it's great views
from up there great views but you know
you just gotta realize the valley of
despair is immediately below you so i
usually am just like i'll never even
start that journey if i if i know how
long it takes i
shy away from doing something but uh
once i get into something like i am a
roller coaster on that on that curve
riding it the whole way through and i
love that i just love being lost on it
so as someone who's done a lot of things
like what what has stood out to you as
things that have been like yeah that was
you know i walked away from that and
that was for me as opposed to like you
said music maybe maybe not so much uh i
mean obviously
the generic umbrella of content creation
you know in all of its aspects is just
like that is so beautiful to me like the
idea of individualized creation is
probably the most profoundly moving
thing of my life it's it and i think for
a lot of people it is and they don't
even realize it like i think humanity in
general is a much more creative species
than we know and it's been like squeezed
out of us uh from an early age to not
pursue uh our own ideas as if they are
the most important thing in the world
and and you know yes there are big
problems out there but to an individual
like an individual level what can you do
besides what you want to do um so many
people out there spend so much of their
lives doing things that other people
want to do and they never look inward on
themselves and i think like the freedom
that people experience in terms of uh
youtube and tick tock and instagram and
all these different ways of making
quote-unquote content online
is something that does kind of lift the
veil of people in terms of their own
individuality is like my ideas are good
uh the audience is a benefit for it and
the money that comes with it is a
benefit but the the freedom and the
realization that like oh my god i can do
whatever i want and it's mine and i can
control it that that is for me the thing
i loved the most and walked away from
and i haven't walked away from it i'm
still clearly in the middle of it
drowning in the ocean of it uh but yeah
i would say that in smaller aspect
though i would say uh the
set life i think that's been really
really fun for me making higher end
productions making stories telling
stories really cohesive stories and
writing god i used to hate writing i
used to i hate it i hated writing god i
hated writing i couldn't stand writing
so how did you feel about writing
i hated it
but no writing i've i've learned to love
writing and i've learned to really
embrace that process of just sitting in
a choir room and tapping away on a
keyboard that is
very very nice that's it's it's really
interesting here you say that because
i felt the same way right like when i
was in school you know growing up and
everyone was always like oh you know the
english you're so good at it this is
that but i always gravitated to math
because the numbers had clean answers
and i liked how definitive it was and
there was no right or wrong there was no
subjectivity i'm like i like the
precision of this uh but everyone's all
but oh but you're a good writer this and
that and and i just hated it i thought
it was i i couldn't stand it it was so
tedious and this and that but you know
now
in at this point in my life i'm tasked
with writing at least three persuasive
essays every single week and
you know using the opportunity to
create my own worlds that are kind of
like fan fictions off of other people's
worlds or doing research papers on thing
like my job is as a writer every single
week at this point and and i and i love
it and i and i enjoy that and i think
that's so creatively satisfying in a way
that had you told
you know
13 14 15 year old me like hey this is
what you're going to be doing for your
life like i never would have believed it
would have been like oh you're gonna be
miserable for so
for so much of my life why would i ever
do this to myself yeah do you think that
it's better because it's a piece of the
the pipeline to make content like it's
writing isn't the end goal writing is a
step on the road to getting there do you
think that has an impact on you
i i think that's definitely part of it
um i think i've gravitated to stuff that
i i naturally like enjoy writing like
writing is a means to an end of me
learning new stuff and getting exposed
to new things so i think that's part of
it too but also like i don't know like
when you're in school right you're
having to be servant to so many masters
and there's so many competing interests
and so many classes that you're jumping
between and this and that whereas now as
an adult i have like this is this is my
focus this is what i'm expected to do
and sure you're still juggling and
you're still serving to so many masters
but i know at the end of the day like
this is a constant in my life and this
is a point of stability and this is a
place where like you said i get to be
quiet and to myself and focus on
whatever fictional world or whatever
blank page is in front of me and it
gives you that respite and a chance to
really be one with yourself and your
voice do you know what's helped me a lot
in terms of getting to that point
what's that this game this game is so
satisfying there's something about it
and i know that like real life power
washing is not nearly as satisfying
having done it it's very satisfying but
not to this level and and it's funny
that we're playing this level because if
people watched my gameplay of this
particular game they would notice that
this level made me angrier than any of
them it was just so frustrating i wanted
to be done with it but in doing this and
i would equate it to writing and i think
a lot of people could understand it it's
like it's an arduous task there's an
enormous amount to do there's so much
and even right now we're only 62 percent
of the way done right right it's
enormous yeah it's enormous this is one
of the biggest maps in the game but now
did you did you choose it so you could
spend more time with me mark that's
sweet yes i actu i actually did 100
because like i knew we've never actually
had a chance to talk and i i knew we've
never actually had a chance to really
get to know each other and i wanted to
make sure that there was as much time as
possible uh to talk about because
there's so much to freaking talk about
not in just youtube but just like
understanding your mind in terms of uh
how you make things
um but
all that all the goodness aside of
making things the next part that i want
to get into is
the negatives of making things and like
things you regret the most like which i
i i want to know
what video that's on your channel
currently still up
do you hate
the most
what video do i hate so i've never
there's only one video that isn't up on
the channel i i can tell you that for a
fact like there there are definitely
videos that i don't like and i wish i
could take down but by my
by my commitment to
hey i produced this i put it out into
the world like it's gonna stay there
like there are certain things where i'm
like you know what it's it's there it's
part of the game theory canon so
the only one that was removed was was a
short mini theory on a scientific game
called foldit uh in which you unfold
proteins
uh and and gamers yeah it's it's
actually fascinating it's kind of like a
puzzle game but it uses real world
proteins and gamers were able to solve
something faster that something that
science had been trying to do for years
i think it took science like four years
of trying to like solve this protein and
gamers were able to do it in like a
couple days um
which is just incredible because their
minds work differently right and they
see it as a puzzle and it's fun and it's
a game whereas the scientists are like
this is work so that was always
fascinating to me but the reason it's
it's off was because you know it was a
different era of youtube and you know i
used my wife's stuff in it and at one
point i'm like oh she's
she's in a lab coat and then i show her
in a
in a swimsuit and it was it was a weird
transition and it was photoshopped and
awkward and she felt awkward like she
was fine with it at the time but then
looking back we're both like yeah
probably not the best so
that was one where i've taken it down so
that's the only episode that doesn't
exist online um the only time i've ever
hidden or privated of a video
um
i'm so sorry to interrupt that just
reminded me of this thing you remember
have you ever looked deep into vsauce
and michael from
the old vsauce videos
that was a real shock like if no one
knows go to vsauce and scroll i hope i'm
sure they're still there go to his old
videos it was like ranking anime boobs
or something
it is and then i think his very first
video is him
in in like the first world of uh super
mario and and him propelling himself
over the green pipes using the power of
farts i believe is is another one
yeah the vsauce channel pivoted hard
into the content that it does nowadays
yeah and i think that's so funny because
like i love that it's still there i
really do i love that it's such a good
move and i'm just so proud i've never
spoken with him but i'm like i admire
that that's that's a ballsy move and i
like that anyway sorry sorry to
interrupt no i didn't know absolutely
and i i mean i think he had subscribes
to probably the the same thing that i do
which is like it's it's part of the
creator journey right it's part of the
history of this channel it's you know
it's
maybe not maybe not the best and you
know shows kind of how far you've come
as a creator and and i think that's
that's important for people who are
the next generation are looking at kind
of the history of of where this whole
thing has come from so i i like you said
i love the fact that those videos still
exist i think it's so funny um and i
think it's always shocking when people
first stumble across those and they're
like wait a minute is this this this the
guy who talks about like
existential space and what happens if
everyone jumped at the planet at the
same time it's like yeah yep i mean hey
who doesn't like uh ranking anime boobs
i mean that's pretty much i think that's
a common human trait
he should remaster that episode you know
like modern vsauce ranks anime boobs
just as a throwback oh yeah oh man
talking about remastering videos i've
thought about that a lot in terms of
just i have so many old videos that i've
done way back when i'm a different
person like both in terms of the
biological sense of every seven years
you change out every atom in your body i
am a different person than when i record
a lot of those um but also just like
from a creator standpoint i am different
and the recent dead space remaster is
like making me think about this if yeah
because i'm i'm going to play that
when it comes out and i thought
how is this different than me going
today and just replaying the old dead
space that i did before would that be
any different and it got me thinking
like i could do that because at this
point i've almost entirely forgotten
that game are there any like theories
that you would ever revisit because
you're like i'm a different person i
learn so much more but that universe is
still compelling like slenderman i
played that game recently i'm like this
still scared me what the hell and i
started thinking what is the story
behind this have you ever done a video
on slenderman like all these different
things that i'm like man i would love to
revisit these things because it's not
like they ever died it's just people
forgot about oh they're right
yes i've seen you
right this whole time just hanging out
on the roof don't mind me um
no it's it's funny that you bring up
slenderman i mean that was the decision
that that that changed the course of the
channel right where uh
halloween what was it 20
2014 or something like that halloween
2014 i i put a a twitter post up and i'm
like hey uh you know i'm trying to
figure out what we're doing for the
halloween theory on on game theory so
here's your choice you got the
slenderman thing it's a little past its
prime but like we've never done it you
guys have requested a lot or there's
this this new game that i see a lot of
people requesting called five nights at
freddy's uh so which would you which
would you like to see done
the right choice yeah
the audience the audience picked the
right choice on that one um yeah and and
i mean obviously the rest is history
there or you know 20
100 books in and whatever but uh oh my
god but uh yeah to this day i've never
i've never done slenderman never never
touched it yeah would be such a fun
throwback because then you could get
into all the marble hornets stuff which
i have only watched like the first video
of and there was three seasons i
discovered recently and there's so much
stuff like people think that the back
rooms is expensive it pales in
comparison to like what was established
in slenderman and that was like 2012
that that started like yep but it's
still just as rich it's just like there
were fewer people to latch on to it and
that's the craziest thing more people
left onto it but more people have
forgotten and then there was a crappy
slenderman movie that came out i was
gonna say let's let's not
yeah let's not forget that movie that
really shook things up yeah yeah man the
timeliness of hollywood always coming in
to save the day
always topical
right
people people still requesting the five
nights at freddy's movie and i'm like
are you sure you guys want at this point
i mean you know
i'm not gonna be in it they haven't
called me they have a call right what's
up man that just tells me that just
tells me that the movie isn't isn't
being filmed yet that's come on yeah i
know right
it's ridiculous but yeah it is
what would you think if like would you
would you do would you would you do this
would you
but oh absolutely absolutely as a
personal request like if you could
because it is kind of just thing that
people forgot and when i played the game
it scared me i was laughing at it
because i was like i opened it up like
oh this whole game
i actually got scared and i'm like how
is this
i've played this before and it like i've
played so many horror games how is this
still scaring me and i was like hmm
maybe uh maybe there's still something
to this yeah no i i would absolutely do
it as long as you promise that you
ignore it like you ignore all the other
episodes i dedicate to you
how many episodes do you dedicate to
this
but also i don't check social media so
when i never see if anyone else ever
attacks because i'm like i i made this
thing i'm like
i don't know
no no i'm just joking about that but uh
but yeah absolutely absolutely i every
year i go back and i'm like should i do
slenderman should i do slenderman and
you know there's usually some other more
timely release or something so whatever
but yeah i've we've been really enjoying
going back and looking at old game
franchises and seeing kind of like
untapped untapped theory potential out
there kind of like to break like you
said on one hand it's nostalgic for
people on the other hand you're exposing
it to a generation of viewers who
missed it the first time and i think
that's one of the the craziest things
about you know being old man youtube
here being
stepdad a cool stepdad of youtube
stepped out of youtube i simultaneously
whipped and naenade uh yeah
me meme dad of youtube over here um
is is is the fact that you know like
when people stop me and they say hey you
matpat i recognize your voice whatever
like i grew up watching you you know
like i i don't watch your stuff anymore
but i grew up watching it was everything
that i watched in in middle school high
school and and that's wild to me like
that we were people's childhoods and and
to think that you know to a lot of
people they're just hopping on this this
journey now and so
they weren't exposed to slender man the
first time it came around they didn't
see all those kind of earth-shattering
videos that really shape the platform
for what it is because
it is you know we're we're 13 14 years
into into youtube at this point and you
know those games are over a decade old
yeah we've forgotten a lot of that stuff
it's new to a lot of people yeah it can
be and i think there's there's something
good about that it's it's kind of like
the the generation of what's in
is like always cycles right but i think
the cycles accelerate over time
people like have to innovate and they
feel forced to innovate so like these
these windows in which like fashion and
music and styles all come back it just
like comes back quicker than ever before
and ever before and always quicker and
it's it's kind of crazy um so just but i
would love i would love a slender thing
because the only time i ever learned
about lore ever is when i watch one of
your videos because i don't ever pursue
it i literally you know it's so weird
i'm like the face of five nights at
freddy's for a lot of people and yet i
haven't read a single book i don't know
what the hell is going on in those games
i don't even beat the hardest modes
anymore i can't i just don't have the
time or care enough to actually dedicate
to it and still people will be like ah
yeah you're the you're the fnaf guy and
i'm like no clearly uh clearly daco or
any of the other people are the fnaf
guys
clearly
what was it i i think i remember uh we
had just gotten done filming uh heist um
i seen in heist and and uh fnaf vr had
just launched and yeah i i played a
couple months ago and i'm like you know
are you picking up that one and you're
like oh i don't think so i'm like oh you
probably should because it's it's pretty
fun and you ended up picking it up i
think when you're in the hotel room or
whatever but yeah yeah i had a guy to
get one and set it up in this like
little library room and play
yeah
yeah that was very nice
but uh okay go on i i don't wanna
the comments are gonna get mad if i
ignore your question so uh videos that i
would
go back so first off remastering uh
we've we remastered the first ever
episode of game theory um a couple years
ago as part of our 10-year anniversary
on the platform i'm like hey it's we've
been here for 10 years obviously a lot
has changed we've changed we've grown um
and so we remastered the first ever
episode of game theory and we did it in
the three different editing and like
visualization styles that we've had over
the years um
so that way not only is it a
retrospective as far as the script goes
i did some like director's commentary
over top about how cringy and bad the
script was uh
at the time and i'm like i can't believe
i said this this is so stupid um but
then also the editors had a really good
time with it because they edited in the
three different styles of what we
consider the three different eras of
game theory where we had uh the
slideshow format where it was just like
ripping down a bunch of pictures and
kind of having them lightly animate
across the screen uh the the
puppeteering element where we did um it
was more like flash based animations and
things like that and then we did uh the
final version where it's a bit more
infographic-y uh
kind of like a hybrid of all the
different styles so we have so we have
remastered some um
you know but yeah i like at some point i
would love to kind of go back and
remaster all those old episodes because
to this day some of those old ones are
my all-time favorites and it's just
you know i'd like
time and people have seen it whatever
but i'd love to kind of give them a new
coat of paint so that way because
because you can't really rehash theories
in a lot of cases but to to
introduce again introduce them to a new
generation or give them the love that
more modern theories get and the level
of polish that more modern theories get
now that we've now that we're better at
what we do
that would be really cool i mean i don't
see why not and i the the even better
thing is like there's no one really to
criticize because the people that watch
those are probably an entirely different
audience from the people that watch uh
younow just like yeah everyone very few
people realize just how much turnover
there is there are people that have
grown up gotten married had kids uh and
then their kids are suddenly watching my
videos there are new humans in this
world that are fans of mine that didn't
exist when i started that is really
weird to think is that crazy yeah how
does it feel to be a formative figure in
people's lives uh you know in their in
their like early lives um it depends on
what videos they're watching
[Laughter]
what your impact on society has been
yeah i have a wide breadth of types of
content you know maybe my uh recent orc
massage video not as uh
formative
i was gonna say the the uh honey pop
play through maybe it may be not
beneficial to society it's not
beneficial maybe not but you know uh but
speaking of beneficial to society i want
to go back to something you mentioned
almost casually and i i think actually
the more i think about the more i'm
interested in this is you working at
youtube
um because you said that like as if as
if it was just like a possibility and i
started thinking like why isn't it a
possibility one of the things that i
think is youtube's biggest detractors
it's not so much like that youtube is
inherently evil people need to realize
this they're not evil it's not even one
thing it's thousands of people working
in a building towards the common goal of
getting their platform money that is the
almost like everyone's goal they have
also cultural goals of like do no evil
which is google's overarching goal which
questionable well actually they've
removed that from their motto
unfortunately like yeah
i hate to break it to you mark but uh
they they quietly uh let that one go
away
of course they did it
that's so beautiful
it's pretty telling yeah but also like
there's a few smaller goals besides
making money but as a company it's
making money however i think one of the
things that youtube could benefit from
the most is literally hiring creators
they don't even have to be full-time but
like consulting creators and actually
using their opinions and experiences to
base policy on and i think of all the
people that i have met on youtube you
would be at the top of my list in terms
of people that i would want youtube to
actually hire on and be able to
influence policy because you have a
creative side that embraces the actual
uh creativity on youtube and understands
and rolls with the punches and has been
through a lot and you have the technical
know-how to actually understand how
decisions impact creators and how they
gamify winning the system and beating
the system uh in a way that even youtube
doesn't realize because i doubt there's
any one person there that understands
the system as well as you or some of the
people on this platform uh well i i'm
honored thank you i appreciate that yeah
what would it take for you to get a job
at youtube because it's really like it's
not so much as like you're bashing down
their door to work there because right
you would be subservient to them but
what what would uh what would it take
for you to work there and also
what circumstances would you do to leave
what you do now or at least partly
remove yourself and then take up the
cause for like championing rights of
other you know youtubers and like making
their lives better sure well i mean i i
will say you know i
and i don't know if these opportunities
have been afforded to you at certain
points but i've always kind of made
myself available to youtube
for product testing or giving like you
know creator roundtables of like hey
we're thinking about doing x y and z
like what do you think um
and you know through
things like that i have
like i saw that they were planning on
doing a second subscription button back
before that was a thing um
you know
which eventually evolved into the
notification bell right and i'm like
that's confusing and stupid
they did not listen to me obviously
they were really convinced about it you
know and
you know it's it's i guess it worked for
him they've kept it this and that but um
but
so i i have done at least as much as i
can to
in in whatever avenues and venues that i
can to to kind of like champion the good
cause beat the drum whatever you know
for free on my own time when they decide
to ask me stuff so i'm working as much
in that capacity as i can um as far as
what it would take for me to do it like
i i'd have to feel like my
theorist journey
was was complete at that point right
like that that i
had done everything that i i wanted to
do and intended to do with theorists and
and with the channel before i kind of
moved on to the broader youtube
ecosystem uh because because the thing
is
there is power in in the videos that we
make you know and and every once in a
while i'll hop on my my little blue
couch and i'll i'll do a meta theory
talking about the state of the union of
youtube and i think
those a lot of times are just as
impactful to youtube as if i had
actually worked there if not more so in
a lot of cases because now the sudden
you're getting the feedback from an
audience you're getting like mainstream
you know to whatever extent it is but
like mainstream attention or
conversation going so sometimes it's
it's funny to think but us as creators
doing videos on our own channels and via
our own outlets on the platform
sometimes can affect change even better
than than working internally
yeah i completely agree like recently
with well i don't know how much change
is being enacted right now but i know
that they are probably talking about it
a lot um with the new age restriction
like problem that's been going on and
corey x kenshin making his video calling
youtube out for discriminatory practices
and the the kind of like double
standards and it is kind of one of those
things where uh in a lot of aspects i do
feel like sometimes i am held as uh like
this poster child for youtube and i
don't like that because i criticize
youtube pretty much at every opportunity
but at the same time i do go to bat for
youtube a lot because again i do believe
in the platform and i think like the
greater good is that i'd rather there be
a platform than not um and i don't trust
tick tock has people's best interests at
heart i don't if anyone actually thinks
that tick tock has your best interest at
heart as a creator i mean my goodness
like oh no you sweet summer child no i i
definitely think that youtube sees what
tic toc is doing with with creator
monetization with their uh their what is
it the creator fund i think is what they
call it you know where it's a it's a
stagnant pool of of money that they just
say like this is an appropriate amount
to divvy up amongst our popular creators
um
you know and they see that oh we don't
have to do an ad share we just kind of
have a pool of money set aside and we
get to decide how much of that money
gets shared instead of a percentage
revenue i am sure that that youtube is
kicking themselves for they're like oh
man i wish we could have done that one
yeah so hopefully they don't take too
many uh pages out of that particular
book yeah and this is what i was talking
about with uh uh there's a these twitch
streamers this is old news by now but
you know when they were just like trying
to challenge their uh copyright
detection system right by flagrantly
playing whatever they wanted and playing
copyright content being like you can't
ban me i'm too big and i'm like they
will amazon will literally shut twitch
down if you cause them too much problems
like the the the option that youtube
took to create their copyright detection
system
was the better option yeah that is the
best case scenario yeah literally the
best case scenario and they didn't have
to do it they could have just given up
youtube had not made them money at any
point but they believed in it they
believed it and i'm like yes you have to
like at some point just believe that the
platform and what it stands for and the
culture that it represents and the
people that it's cultivating is worth it
at some point and i do think more than
any other company out there youtube has
done that does that mean i forgive them
for everything no does that mean they
deserve to be forgiven for anything no
it's a company come on but there's also
people in there that do legitimately
care and do legitimately fight for the
creators a lot and it's it's like that
cynicism the cynicism is the death of
any
uh group organization platform anything
when you get cynical that you don't have
the ability to change something it's not
the arguments it's not the like fight
like it that's not what does it that's
what's good and healthy it's changed it
motivates it but it's the cynicism like
nothing can improve i might as well give
up that's what those things right and
and i think you know a good point to
illustrate exactly that is by the nature
of of you know my history in the space
consulting people being analytically
minded things like that i've gotten to
talk to a lot of different creators from
different platforms and hear their
experiences and you you talk to the
viners right and and some of the biggest
viners at at the time you know who are
who are crushing it in that world right
before it the whole platform shut down
and they're like yeah vine brought us
all in to a room and asked like hey
what should we do with this platform
like what what is going wrong like how
do we how do we improve at this and that
and they brought all their top creators
into the same space there was all this
creative brainstorming happening and
nothing got done you know like they had
a huge list of things and and vine
decided to ignore it every single
recommendation that all their like
heaviest users and most popular people
were were offering and none of it got
implemented and as a result you know
vine then proceeded to disappear and and
i think you know
like i i make the joker about like the
the the double subscription and this and
that and i've seen those sorts of things
but at least youtube is having those
conversations and and i've seen them
change things based on the conversations
that they're having with with their
creators sometimes and and so
that that is something like you said
there it's not going to be every time
creators aren't going to win every time
you know there are other factors that
need to be considered but at the very
least they they are willing to to keep
an open ear and be open to changes and
things like that
yeah and i think that again to youtube's
credit
they have enacted some change from
people's suggestions i have experienced
it myself i can't remember specifically
what it is it's not like groundbreaking
things but i've shared youtube out on
things and they have talked to me and
things have occurred from those
conversations i'm sure you to have many
examples um that you don't need to list
right now but it's just like it is it is
an evolving thing and the more people
care about the platform the more people
fight for the platform and want it to be
better and make it active and obvious
that they want to be a better the better
it is as much as they push shorts and as
much as i don't really like shorts you
know and i get it whatever it's fine i'm
not gonna regularly make shorts but it's
like that it's it's these things that
they have to i i know it they have to
there's some executive room and they're
like
we need to compete with tick shock and
this way do it better because that's
what google does they copy things and
that's fine um
but you know there are ways to improve
it and it is still a fantastic place to
i i think i i don't know if you agree
with this but i think youtube is one of
the best places on the internet
maybe the best place to have as a
creative outlet for people that want to
make video content specifically yeah i
mean it's it's hard to deny because
because again like just the sheer policy
of hey we will share ad revenue like we
are in this together you know our
success is your success and your success
is our success like i think that level
of partnership is something that you
will never see another platform really
truly do in earnest and and like i said
the fact that tick-tock has shown that
hey creators are
willing to to shell out a bunch of
content and do this for like whatever
pool of money we deem i think it shows
that mentality that youtube has of we
share 5545 of the ad split is is a thing
of the past i don't think you will ever
see another platform do anything like
that again i would agree yeah i agree
which is kind of sad
right exactly
yeah sad yeah anyway i wanna i wanna
we've talked about youtube so much and
there's only 15 left of uh this house so
it'll be done in a flash as things go by
um to close this off i just want to say
uh thank you so much for
being here number one um but number two
what do you love to do in your spare
time that has nothing to do with videos
literally no games no nothing like
literally what is your go-to outside of
this
loop right spare time mark
you see these big footprints did you do
anything about the did you talk about
the big footprints oh oh we have talked
about the big footprints okay is there a
video about that sorry i just i just saw
them and i remembered i was like i think
in this particular video i called out
for you to do something i kind of
watched it yeah i was i was actually
gonna say mark so you know you you've
been largely right about the lore of
this game
yeah you you were largely right
you were right that there there is
indeed a volcano that is erupting off in
the distance and it this is all tied to
actually atlantis there's all sorts of
crazy stuff yeah
[Laughter]
we have to do an update video because we
did it before
they were really taking the lore
seriously and and then between you
calling out oh there's there's the
volcano and how's everything getting so
dirty and this must be all ash and
whatever um and us doing a video kind of
following that up and and looking into
the logistics of all that uh the
developers reached out to us and they're
like oh well we're taking it seriously
now so keep an eye out um
and and largely you know what you and
and we
predicted has come to pass so
i think that was one of those things
where i do this for your theories a lot
or my fan series is like when they get a
really good idea i go
oh so you've found it out have you
oh you deduced my puzzles great and i'm
sick of writing down all these great
golden ideas
i i do appreciate when i do episodes
that you do happen to see and uh and you
text me and you're like hey matt uh good
way to figure that one out or like oh i
didn't realize that had lore
yeah but anyway back to the other
question because i could talk about
youtube all day but what do you do
outside youtubing yeah uh so outside of
of all of this this crazy stuff um i
i like i consume everything and i mean
that's partly doing work so i i love
going to see movies i love watching tv
you know watching new relevant tv shows
better call sol just finished so like i
like just again consuming a lot of
different media to to learn from it to
grow from it maybe brainstorm ideas uh
but outside of that i also just i love
being in nature um i love being active i
love swimming i love rock climbing um i
don't get to do it that much uh but now
that uh my son ali he's he's four at
this point uh and he's old enough to go
to places like trampoline parks and so
yeah which is awesome and i'm yeah and
i'm working on
getting good at doing
flips and somersaults and and backflips
and and front flips and stuff and so i'm
teaching myself trampolining and he's
old enough to be strapped into a harness
and start climbing like those rock walls
at places like that and so he and i are
you know doing rock climbing and stuff
so that's i love that sort of thing how
old is your son uh he's four four wow
yeah that's crazy to think about it it
it is it's if it's crazy for you to
think about it it's even wilder for me
to think about because i mean you see
everyone says like oh they grow up so
fast whatever and you you kind of look
up and you're like oh this is this is a
an actual human being with its own
thoughts and opinions and likes and
dislikes and and when did that happen
and how did he get to be you know this
way and have these tastes and interests
it's it's wild to see yeah oh man that's
gotta be crazy but that i mean that's
great to hear like in my spare time and
this is like a kind of my detriment and
i am perpetually stuck in thinking about
content creation i i actually don't
escape the loop uh i i always think
about what i'm making next it's
to the detriment of my like friendships
and stuff i don't hang out with people
unless they're working case in point the
first time we're
having a chance to sit down for making a
video yeah um whereas at any point i
could have like text you said like hey
let's hang out and i i will do that
after this and i think we should
definitely like hang out at some point
you should come over to my house and
just like
see the sunset from my back porch that
would be really nice that would be great
are you this is a question i've always
wanted to ask you is can you get out and
and do things um because because here's
the thing right i recognize that at this
point whenever i go out i'm i'm probably
recognized about
you know at least at least once if not
three to four times depending on on
where i'm going and i'm i'm a guy who is
a floating image that kind of talks and
gets animated around it's a picture of
me from like seven years ago whereas you
i mean your face is everywhere your your
channel is is massive i i can you go
like if it was like hey let's go to a
trampoline park like are we renting out
that trampoline park for the night so
that way you get you get a night arrest
are you able to kind of trampoline
with with with the populace i mean it's
so i just deal with it i'm never gonna
rent out a place for myself but uh yes i
i do get recognized a lot it's not i'm
not saying that like it's a problem but
the most recent example is just like
yesterday i was going through the
drive-through and uh
one of the employees ran outside to say
like
it's it's lovely and it's an honor but
it does like detract from that sense of
normality that's just like i don't know
why this is occurring um
and that is like another part of content
creation that if anything i think it's
probably
it just makes me i never understand why
people chase fame i i never understand
never never had i'm honored by it um but
it's like i am the type of person i like
to go to a restaurant by myself or at
least i used to i can't i can't do that
anymore
uh the advent of masks has helped a lot
you know that that kind of helps right
some people snipe me from like across
the hall even in my mask like i'll i'll
have sunglasses and a mask on and people
are like oh markiplier usually as soon
as i open my mouth people
they hear one word and they're like oh
markiplier there yep it's always the
voice that's that's the thing i always
hear like i thought i recognized you but
then i heard your voice ordering or
whatever yeah that's always it
yeah it is one of those things so
unfortunately no but again i just it's
just like a part of life now and i i
would never bemoan it it's an honor and
at the same time it's like
it's just something i i deal with it's
part of the process but then again i
hardly ever go outside so it's like i
don't have to deal with that that much
no you're not you're not much an
outdoorsy person i mean you appreciate
your sunset on your own balcony so i
appreciate that i do i i like nature i
do but it's just like because i am
trapped in the cycle of content creation
i just love making i am addicted to it i
would say that it's a full-blown
addicted addiction at this point and
it'll probably eat me up until my dying
day but thankfully uh amy my girlfriend
is here to make sure that i stay sane
and grounded and i take trips and i i
take breaks regularly and i think about
things that are outside of uh the next
project that i'm working on yeah um i do
think that that that chase is addictive
i think there are many youtubers you
could probably think of that are
addicted to the process of making of
course uh and i'm not one to call out
because i i do the same thing but at the
same time it's like there it is can be a
problem when you detract everything and
and i've tried to get better about it by
balancing the human element of it by not
exploiting uh the people around me to
try to like live my life where i have to
make content all the time i
sometimes i just want to go out for a
walk and i think that's the biggest
change in my life is just
just being able to recognize that i can
go out for a walk is very very nice yeah
yeah and and uh you know you mentioned
this but uh that's the other thing i
would throw on on kind of like the old
hobbies list for me is is travel uh my
wife steph we have a goal to visit uh a
hundred countries uh in our lifetime wow
yeah and so we're currently sitting at
27 28. um
yeah so we're doing pretty good
obviously the last couple years have
been tough for that um both god i'm so
sorry my first thought was like and
literally my brain was like oh a travel
channel would be so fun
[Laughter]
no you're totally right though like i've
i've thought about that at some point
you know i i think that there's room for
a cool travel channel that we could do
uh the problem with travels i mean here
if you want to get really nerdy with the
problem with travel is travel is very
location specific and so p when people
are looking for travel related content
they're looking for a specific country
or a specific place and so you have to
be really smart about how you're
balancing your programming to make sure
that you're not falling out of people's
algorithms so
i i've
i too mark think about content a lot uh
and that definitely overthinks so i you
you and i are in the same boat and and
so i i definitely understand where
you're coming from oh man but you know i
i do wonder about that philosophy
because i never think about that all i
think of like and all i've ever done is
like if the content's good enough people
will come that's how i've always
operated and so far it has worked for me
when you look at my channel does it make
you mad
sometimes
you know i put no thought into what i do
i don't really and then suddenly i'll
make that pokemon video and like
everyone will do it and i'm like i don't
know what happened i don't know why my
videos do well i couldn't tell you the
first thing other than that i try to
make them good sometimes but i don't
always even try to do that sometimes my
videos are garbage and i know it and
everyone knows it but no one seems to do
anything about it no one calls me out on
my shitty videos
no i i like here's the thing does it
make me mad no uh am i jealous sometimes
absolutely
absolutely you know if you're if you're
talking about like you know biggest
regret or whatever on one hand i'll i
would say like oh i should have started
a let's play channel instead of instead
of like a let's do a heavy research
channel but then i think about i'm like
would i
would i you know enjoy the content that
i that i do as much as i do maybe maybe
not i like i'm so happy with the stuff
that we we put out and it's so
creatively satisfying for me so on on
one hand it's like oh i wish i could do
that but on the other hand it's like
well no but i really am happy with with
where we are so
but yeah to say that i'm you know not
jealous of sometimes when when you do a
video
you're doing like the 30-second like
dunk on me because i i was i did a
crappy pokemon and that one gets more
views than my original video where i
talk about how i made that pokemon
whatever that's fine yeah yeah it's fine
it's fine we're all good
but for me it's like that's that was the
only response i could make possibly it's
just a 30-second quick dismissal and
it was great i loved it as much as i
want to make an extended video because
my real thought is like of course i want
to make a video talking about like matt
you seriously just put giant boobs on it
and it'll be great that's all you have
it's that simple man
i can't say that in my response video of
course yeah i couldn't say that at all
no i gotta gotta be in the in the
character of things the zeitgeist of
them oh the zeitgeist theory is again
yeah but no i it is one of those things
where like i guess technically i do
think about like the more technical
aspects but mine is always like the
interaction i always think of like you
know improv exercise i'm sure you've
taken improv before as well yes yeah
it's like what is good for the bit
what's good for the the joke what's good
for that and that's where i lean in a
lot on things yeah as opposed to what's
good for the algorithm i don't really
care what other people want i care what
i would want to happen in that moment
it's like yeah i would want me to be so
dismissive of this even if inside i'm
like just put hits
even though i want to say that i was
like you know this is better for the
moment so i guess i do think
strategically but it's just like a not
as analytical number focused strategies
as a performer as a performer who
understands you know what what the
audience is how the audience is going to
react absolutely 100
i mean that's that's why i loved about
doing theater back when i was doing
theater and i was i was directing shows
right is i
would always approach my shows from the
the perspective of the audience and i
like what is the audiencing and what do
they expect to see in this moment and do
i want to give them that or do i want to
give them something else
and and that was
kind of one of the the weird quirks that
i had as a director and and i totally
see that and i think you know looking at
content in that way is is very smart so
oh thank you very much and and i gotta
say for those who don't know uh matthew
patrick here is an incredible actor and
really incredible performance like the
stuff you did with mac on on set like
was just like it was
it was wonderful the breakdown was just
like so fun it was it was just a shame
like we couldn't put it all in it was
just like wonderful and then like what
you did with the i call him the
prospector he's not the prospector the
hermit yeah the hermit
originally it was just some old mining
prospector that was the original
incarnation of that character um uh but
just like it's it's really stuff have
you ever thought about doing acting in
like a bigger like movie or tv show or
something like that i you know i on one
hand it's it's funny that you bring that
up because steph and i have this
conversation a lot where like again i
love to go see theater shows i like to
go you know to all these different
things and and watch and consume
everything and i lived and breathed
theater you know for the longest time in
my life i i fully anticipated making a
career out of theater
as my professional living from here
until the end of days
and i go back to see theater
and on one hand i'm like oh it'd be fun
to do to go back and and do that and
live that fantasy life and stuff but i
go back and and it feels so
superficial and so dated as an art form
because
because of the the world we exist in now
and and this cool interactivity of
content and the authenticity of of the
characters that we are and the
personalities that we are in line and
stuff and so i see it and there's always
an artifice in theater but the artifice
feels so much more pronounced
in this era of digital content i'm like
i don't i don't know if i i would like
to do this i think it would be fun for
me but would i ultimately be and it
would be fun to kind of revisit a past
part of my life and it's always fun to
have a chance to
to memorize lines do blocking like i
love the pro like you mentioned how you
love the production process of a movie i
and of a video i love the production
process of theater and i think it's it's
magical and wonderful and i love when
the lights come up and and the energy of
an audience and this and that
there's nothing like it but i also
recognize that creatively
it it doesn't resonate for me
the way that it used to and it feels
very different as an art form at this
point yeah there's what's fun and then
there's what's fulfilling and i think
it's not touching it would be fun like
just like i said i did a tour and it was
fun but doing it again would not be
fulfilling like it was fulfilling to be
able to go through that experience once
but if i did it again it would ring
hollow and like that feeling of
hollowness is actually i think a good
instinct um because not many people can
even recognize this idea like what once
was will not be you know it it it will
not be the same if you relive something
in in these memories that was a big part
of unisonness like reliving it is not
the same as experiencing it when it was
there the content is what it is and it's
good it's not the same as the overall
experience well and honestly that that
was one of the things that got me out of
theater when i was kind of making that
transition because again like i fully
anticipated being a theater professional
acting and directing doing some lighting
design this and that and then you know i
worked off off broadway for a bit i
toured around for a while as both an
actor and director i did a ton of shows
but what ultimately got me out of
theater was
two things first off uh it was the the
constant like living out of a suitcase
and like there was no stability in it
and that was tough for me to handle but
also you know i i lived in worked in new
york at that time and i saw what
constituted a successful life in theater
and it was
doing spider-man turn off the dark eight
times every week and you know you have
to hit all the beats at exactly the
right time otherwise the orchestra is
going to get paid over time and you're
going to cost the show its budget and
you know and and you lose exactly to
your point you lose
the spontaneity and and the in the
moment-ness that theater that makes
theater and live theater and live
performance so exciting and so
you know impactful because everything
has to be so regimented and robotic in
order to kind of like meet your quota at
the end of the week it's it's a business
and and seeing the reality of that was
was a real
you know defining moment for me in my
life where i'm like oh that's that's a
bummer that's sad i'm i miss that so
yeah letting go of what once was
and uh
it's it's just like it'll never be the
same
just like
how
when uh
i was never the same
after i'm trying to think of a funny
example i was trying to make a joke to
like really make light of this profound
thing i couldn't think of anything
like he's reaching he's reaching he's
gonna find it he's gonna find it i
couldn't find it couldn't find it no you
you get to keep your meaning i get to i
get to not make fun of it for one more
moment i the only reason i'm saying that
is because we're at two percent away
from being done and this is the most
arduous two percent where we have to
hunt down all the stupid last pieces
that are
clean
not cleaned yet
but uh we're closing we're closing up
here and the reason i bring up the
acting thing is mostly just because if
say someone that maybe you knew was
making a show like a tv show or
something like filming a pilot or
something sure yeah of course in the
very near future
sure you know uh like let's say early
next year yeah would you be available to
uh be a part of it
oh apps i'm absolutely yes 100
instant instant especially if it was a
director that i had known and worked
with and whose work i had respected
absolutely okay all right okay cool good
good good just checking just putting the
feelers out because you never know when
opportunity no it might arise and and
and that's exactly it right like i think
too
to what you're saying before and you
know like we exist in a world where
you with less so but for me for sure
like the content that i'm kind of
expected to produce on on the channel is
is you know
you can mix it up to only a certain
amount but
at a certain point you got to kind of
deliver to the audience what what
they're hoping for what they expect or
you know subvert it but you can't do it
that often and so for me to have the
opportunity
to
you know lose my mind or
express that like unhinged character or
you know what have you i
i relish those opportunities to to
really ham it up and and step outside of
myself it's great yeah man and this is
like kind of like my folly is because i
always i i operate on you energy i don't
know if i've ever told you this but i do
um elixir and i guess censored uh make
it family friendly
no it's fine i i operate on [ __ ] you
energy and it's not so much that i wanna
like be a part of hollywood in that
traditional sphere i just wanna prove to
him that i can do it better i literally
just want to say hey your ways are cool
and you make cool [ __ ] sometimes i can
do that too
and just like that's how i've always
been with with anything i make half of
what i make is just because i'm like
trying to prove a point to someone
it's like a bet like it's a bet and i'm
like yeah no i'm gonna fall through it
i'll do it it was like uh my friends
were telling me that like if i was part
of creator clash 2 which have you ever
thought about boxing all the youtubers
are doing it yeah right it's a popular
thing to do these days um i i have
thought about it uh actually
i was asked to be a part of it and i
thought it was a joke like i didn't know
how to respond initially when when he
reached out to me he's like hey like do
you want have you ever thought about
boxing you want a box and
i'm like
seriously like i i had no idea whether i
was supposed to take it seriously or not
but um i've thought about it here's the
thing that i would do with it
i would want it to be
i i would wanna
again me being the the guy that i am i'm
like oh let's let's make it theatrical i
wanna subvert expectations i want to get
in the ring throw a few punches and then
the lights go out
and when the lights come back up the
ring is full of dancers and we all do
like a dance together and then there's a
scripted dance sequence and it's it's
not at all what you would have expected
and it's it's it's crazy um or maybe
there's some lore component attached to
it where you know the lights go out
punches are thrown lights go out and
suddenly people are missing or the
audience is gone or something like that
and it's something crazy like that and
there's this this wild like oh i wonder
what happened so it's not just oh we're
getting in a ring and
you know throwing fists at each other
but
you're treating it you know like like a
theatrical show you want to do wwe
yeah yeah i would i think i created a
rumble yeah
that's exactly it yeah i'll contact
idubbbz i'll be like what about the
rumble
i mean honestly i think it would do
great i think logan paul is doing uh wwe
at the moment
i think i think wwf world wrestling
federation but wwe is also a thing
aren't they they're both world wrestling
something
there's like the world wildlife
foundation so it must be wwe i think no
no there's www it's world wrestling
federation i know that i know for a fact
that wwf is a thing okay all right then
uh yeah he's doing that and he's doing
pretty well and i think i think it went
well but at the same time
there's the upper underside like it's
it's hidden
oh
the upper underside you know the
tippy-toppy
like this thing up here yeah i got it i
got it
okay all right so what's left are window
frames and then um
little bits and bobs that are around
here
sure sorry anyway you were saying so are
you gonna are you gonna are you gonna
punch people oh no no this was a uh i
was asked to be with it as well i was
trying to make another point but yeah i
will be part of the next one but i won't
be boxing and the reason uh someone said
this about my personality because i run
on you energy is like i would be great
at boxing simply for the fact that i
would die standing before i fell down
and i'm like i think that's a really
nice compliment that someone gave me i'm
so boneheaded that i would rather die
than give up and i'm like ah that's so
sweet of you
and at the same time probably um but
just because like yeah i i also i hate
being bad at something so if i did
decide to box i would it would consume
my life and i wouldn't be able to do
anything else and i don't i just don't
have time for that also i don't want to
be punched in the face why does everyone
want to get punched in the face i've
been punched have you been punched in
the face i have never been punched in
the face mark i've been punched in the
face it sucks
it's fun absolutely you know what it
feels like
what's it feel like it feels like being
punched in the face that's what it feels
like
imagine what being punched in the face
is like that's what it feels like it
sucks why does everyone want to get
punched in the face so badly i don't
understand
i have i've been surprised by the fact
that people have so enthusiastically and
and like without
w without like hesitation it seems like
people being like yeah let's just do
this let's just go
and and
i think part of it is like curiosity
right exactly to your point like what
does being punched in the face look like
can you hold up
under pressure like that again a good
excuse to you know to to also get
healthy get in shape things like that i
do get that yeah people do crave that
change and i i do appreciate that i'm
all about like yes that change is
important you should pursue it and and
yes absolutely and and i think um i'll
be part of it in a way that is not
necessarily doing uh
uh the actual boxing of it but i do i do
appreciate boxing boxing is one of the
few sports that i have watched
throughout my life and and do appreciate
i love a boxing movie i love the rocky
movies i love um creed i love all them
they're very fun very great movies um
and it's a good sport and good
discipline i just worry about people
being hurt that's right oh absolutely
yeah like people especially worry about
myself being hurt
yeah yeah you want to protect that brain
you've got you've got you've got a lot
of thinking to do a lot of theorizing
that brainy head inside my hand and
inside my skull skull points
yeah so okay oh go ahead no no no you go
well i was gonna say so
not to go back to the content creation
stuff but i am curious so you asked me
earlier what happens if youtube
disappears
what what and you said you you would
thrive in the mosh pit and stuff but
what would you do
what did i do yeah um
pretty much the same thing i'm doing
right now which is i'm going to be
pursuing power washing yeah yeah pretty
much probably maybe i'll get back into
world of warcraft who knows nah i'd
write a lot i'd probably write a book
and then i would make a movie which i'm
already doing and then i would make a tv
show which i'm already doing um i'm busy
enough as it is that i could fill my
time no problem um
yeah it's just like for me creativity
extends so far beyond just making a
youtube video but it is like what you
said there is something magic about what
youtube
offers the
the creativity that nowhere else does
and it is something to protect and i
will fight to protect it and i think
everyone should and i think that anyone
who doesn't fight to protect it doesn't
actually care about it yeah they should
and
that's that's a beautiful thing
where's his last goddamn right what are
these are just gonna say well all right
here we are
i keep thinking that it's gonna end and
be like we'll have a nice little button
but no no it's never gonna happen
you are stuck here with me forever no
i'm not you're stuck here with me
i'm talking about like out give me uh
give me the button to delete your
channel come on i'll you can trust me
with it come on come on oh yeah the
button yeah what is it
what if you deleted your channel if uh
remove my torment yeah what if i freed
you yeah
that at least at least give me a final
upload man i gotta i gotta get it i
gotta get a final theory no no no abrupt
ending no even even even oona's honest
got got to say goodbye at the end right
against my best wishes
no no just kidding
where's his last thing
an upper deck rim joint what is an upper
deck rimchill they're the things way up
top like you can't reach them but i'm
looking at all of them and it i don't
see a single one that is
has any
stuff like if you hit i'm there wait i'm
there on an upper deck rim joist do you
see one that's not
oh yes i got one
left where where those are the rings
around the trees mark oh
the tree rings yeah tree rings oh i
wasn't looking at those okay so you i
don't even see where you are anymore
here i i then we have steps you you find
the steps i can find the joist okay
steps is either that spiral staircase uh
the steps here someone must have missed
something on the other yeah i missed
something on the other side so done here
all right well any last words before
this video abruptly ends no i got one
more joist mark where's the leg's joints
i don't see you anymore your character
model disappeared
oh there you are no you're he just gave
up he's like i'm done
where is this
where's the choice i see it i see it i
see it i see it all right well say
goodbye because it's uh what do you got
to promote well your channel your
channel yeah sure yeah check out check
out food theory and uh keep an eye out
for a new channel happening sometime
before the end of the year
it'll be something theory yeah we got we
got a new one no one has ever
to date no one has predicted what it's
gonna be so i'm excited in my world you
can theorize and be a nerd about
everything and overthink all your
favorite things and we found a new
category that we're overthinking and i
cannot wait i'm so excited about it all
right we'll go check that out and look
forward to the future slenderman episode
dedicated to mark dedicated to me and
i'll go catch up on some of those things
that i need to
watch i'll say i'll send you a greatest
hits compilation mark i promise thanks
man thank you well thank you for taking
the time i know this was a longer one
but i felt like it needed to be just one
how much
the
history there is on no it's it's a
pleasure
to this day in all of my history of
content creation sitting down in front
of the live audience and and the people
watching uh during the saint jude stream
was one of the most real and memorable
moments to me it was it was great so
you know it was it was it was nice
getting a chance to chat oh good i
barely remember anything i was so tired
i i never know what markiplier i'm going
to get when i step into the room with
you so
yeah it keeps me on my toes and it keeps
things spicy and exciting oh good well
thank you so much for your time everyone
go check out matpat you've definitely
seen one of his videos and you should
definitely see more if not you've seen
my memes yeah definitely the memes
always spicy always beautiful
all right well take care and uh my next
guest will be whoever i choose shut up